كريستيانو رونالدو في نادي النصر وترينايت
في موسم الرياض السعوديه تحتل العناوين
الابرز على مواقع التواصل في بدايه العام
الجديد واجواء البهجه تعود لسماء لندن
[موسيقى]
عامه الاحتفالات العالم بمناسبه راس السنه
الميلاديه وميزها هذا العام الى جانب
الالعاب الناريه الساخره بالالوان عروض
الطائرات بدون طيار المبهره والتي عادت
الى السماء لندن بعد سنوات الجايحه ورسمت
سوره الملك الجديد تشارلز الثالث فوق مع
علمها التاريخيه
[موسيقى]
كما شهدت دوله الامارات احتفالات مميزه
براس السنه وابرزها كان في ابوظبي دبي راس
الخيمه التي خططت لتحقيق رقمين قياسيين
باكبر عدد من الطائرات بدون طيار
المستخدمه باطلاق الالعاب الناريه في وقت
واحد واكبر جمله تم تشكيلها في السماء
باستخدام 673 طائره بدون طيار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وكان الحفل الغنائي الابرز بالعالم العربي
ليله راس السنه في موسم الرياض التي احيا
فيها اثنا عشر نجمه من نجوم الغناء العرب
النسخه الثانيه من تريونايت التي حققت
تفاعلا كبيرا على مواقع التواصل في مصر
والسعوديه وشارك في الحفل الانغام اصاله
نصري نجوى كرم نوال الزغبي لطيفه التونسيه
نانسي عجرم اليسا وليد توفيق عاصي الحلاني
صابر الرباعي وائل كفوري وبهاء سلطان
وكانت مشاركه سلطان الطرب جورج وسوف
مفاجاه هذه الليله الغنائيه المرصعه
بالنجوم
باذابه الجليد بينه وبين مواطنته اصاله
التي لم يجمعه بها اي اغنيه خلال الحفل
ولا يزال الخلاف مستمرا على ما يبدو بين
الاخيره والصديقتي الامس انغام ومن ابرز
ما قدمه نجوم تريونايتد من حبيبي انا
الشهير بين وائل كفوري ونوال الزغبي بعد
سبعه وعشرين عاما على تقديم هذا الضيوف
لاول مره
ولا على الحدث الابرز في اليوم الاخير من
العام الماضي الاعلان رسميا عن انضمام
اسطوره كره القدم كريستيان رونالدو الى
نادي النصر السعودي وقد عبر وزير الرياضه
السعوديه عبد العزيز بن تركي الفيصل في
تغريده له على تويتر عن سعادته بتواجد من
وصفه باحد افضل لاعبي العالم لبدء مسيرته
الجديده في السعوديه كما اعتبر رئيس نادي
النصر بان التعاقد مع رونالدو لا يستهدف
كسب مباراه او بطوله بلنقل تجارب عظيمه
واحترافيه عاليه والهام لجيل شغوف
بالرياضه ودعى متابعه على تويتر في
الاستمتاع بفصل من فصول التطور الهائل في
مملكه العز بحسب تعبيره وبحسب نادي النصر
فقد قالك كريستيانو انه متشوقون لتجربه
دوري كره قدم جديد في دوله مختلفه
واخيرا اختار الفنان المصري تامر حسني
الاحتفال على طريقته الخاصه براس السنه
الجديده باداء مناسك العمره مع زوجته بسمه
بوسيل التي نشرت لهما صورا من الحرم المكي
عبر حسابها الرسمي على انستغرام